I've been breaking in yeah maybe it's
still not a thing
god damn it so I'm making this video as
an important announcement I am quitting
YouTube forever
did I say forever I'm in a week I'm in a
week don't cry that was crying no one
cares
everyone is celebrating ah so me and my
dad travel a lot we go to different
places and it's most of the times it's
through business stuff we wear suits and
not really actually one time but
irrelevant so by the time you're
watching this video me and my staff will
have gone to Japan and we're gonna stay
there for a week so I I didn't prepare
any videos I'm sorry you're not getting
anything I'm kidding
out let's do seek him out so I played
through the entire thing all ready and
prepared videos of that so that will go
up every day while I'm gone it's a
really really cool deal see like I
really really enjoyed it so I it should
be good
you should be finebros don't worry I'm
worried there won't be as much variation
of course and all that I am I just want
to say it because every time something
changes with my channel everyone freaks
the [ __ ] out but um it's because I'm not
here don't freak out here let me rub
your belly it's gonna be okay baby it's
gotta be okay sweat why is it wet I just
want to say thanks for understanding and
thanks for being support even though I'm
going away I'll be for it it's breakfast
for you stay awesome breasts
love you
it was